- This is Mr. Mac.
He's an Aldabra Tortoise,
a giant tortoise species that can live
past 180 and may have
the longest life span
of any creature on the planet.
(orchestral music)
Hailing from the Aldabra Atoll,
a small cluster of coral
islands in the Indian Ocean,
the Aldabra Tortoise is massive.
Endowed with a domed shell, long neck,
and strong claws, they
can grow to be longer
than four feet and can
weigh as much as 500 pounds.
They live in grasslands
and subsist on a diet
of dry, nutrient rich vegetation.
An Aldabra Tortoise has never met
a blade of grass it didn't like.
And it won't be deterred from eating it
even if it takes a while to reach it.
But the tortoises have had a harder time
finding food because
of habitat destruction
caused by humans and
increasingly climate change.
This is the Aldabra Tortoise.
(orchestral fanfare)